vamos a ver uno de los problemas
clásicos del cálculo pero sin dudarlo
uno de los más hermosos es de los que
más me gustan algunos me ha pedido que
haga una modificación de este problema
sin embargo vamos a verlo tome usted una
hoja de cartón cuadrada de 24
centímetros de lado entonces voy a
suponer no no quiero una hoja de cartón
rellena que una hoja de cartón que
solamente tenga el borde bien y que
tenga 24 centímetros de lado es cuadrada
y tiene 24 centímetros de lado entonces
aquí es 24 aquí 24 y aquí está muy bien
y después corte las esquinas pero corte
de las esquinas de una cierta forma que
cada uno de esos cortes tenga la misma
distancia es decir si yo voy a cortar
esta esquina de aquí le voy a poner con
un nuevo color con este color
eso está esquina de acá ojo todas las
esquinas son cuadradas porque voy a
cortar lo mismo de cada uno de mis
cortes entonces esta de aquí y estar acá
y ya que cortó las esquinas ahora forme
una caja con los lados que le quedaron
entonces voy a suponer que aquí voy a
hacer un doblez aquí otro doblez aquí
otro doblez y aquí otro dobles ya tengo
aquí mi base y cada uno de mis lados y
con esto voy a formar una caja la cual
no tiene tapa es muy importante eso mi
caja no tiene tapa y cada uno de mis
lados le voy a cortar lo mismo por lo
tanto si cada cada una nuestra le voy a
cortar lo mismo pues yo puedo poner que
aquí le voy a cortar una cierta cantidad
x una cierta cantidad x una cierta
cantidad x x x x ahora bien la pregunta
de mi problema va a ser dados los cortes
x que le hicimos a la caja encuentra en
la caja con mayor volumen ahora lo que
quiero es maximizar el volumen entonces
vamos a pintar la caja bueno supongamos
que esta es la base de mi caja y dese
cuenta que la base de mi caja se forma
con el cuadrado del centro entonces esto
es uno de los lados pero cuánto va a
medir uno de los lados pues si yo sé que
todo
mi hoja de cartón media 24 entonces yo
estoy quitando 2 x una x una parte y una
x de la otra parte y entonces 24 x - x
es 24 menos 2 x pero esto más de cada
uno de los lados entonces si este lado
balde 24 menos 2 x éste también va a
valer 24 menos 2x y el otro también va a
valer 24 menos 2x y 24 menos 2 x muy
bien espero que hasta aquí vayamos bien
y claros ahora voy a tomar la altura de
mi caja la voy a dibujar esta va a ser
uno de mis lados otro
otro de mis lados este es el último de
mis lados y ya tengo mi caja y no tiene
tapa eso es el problema en mi caja no
tiene tapa bien pero cuánto va a ser
cada uno de mis lados pues la altura de
mis lados es x
x porque es lo que yo le conté a mi casa
es cada uno de mis cortes muy bien si ya
tengo cada uno de mis lados entonces
supongamos que este va a ser una cara de
mi no no no lo voy a poner con otro
color esta va a ser una cara de mi caja
esta va a ser una cara por ejemplo este
sería otra cara de mi caja está de aquí
y que corresponde en mi hoja a estar acá
esta sería otra cara y esta sería la
última cara muy bien ya tengo mis cuatro
caras ahora lo que yo quiero es un corte
una x tal que mi volumen sea máximo es
decir creo que mi punto crítico sea un
máximo que tenga concavidad hacia arriba
como se ve un punto crítico que a su
alrededor tenga concavidad hacia arriba
no voy a dibujar para que lo tengan en
cuenta va a ser algo así y aquí estaría
mi punto crítico muy bien entonces la
idea es encontrar un volumen que dependa
de x que sea máximo entonces vamos a
encontrar la fórmula para el volumen la
función que me describe el volumen quien
va a ser pues es la función del volumen
de un prisma que es el lado por el ancho
por el árbol es decir x por 24 menos 2 x
por 24 menos 2 x como tenemos una base
cuadrangular pues es el área de la base
por uno de los lados y ya está y ahora
sí voy a multiplicar 24 menos 2 x por 24
menos 2 x es un vídeo en el cuadrado
perfecto entonces
24 por 24 lo voy a hacer aquí no me
quiero equivocar no quiero lastimar mi
ego esta vez por lo tanto voy a tratar
de hacerlo aquí con calma 4x4 16 y
llevamos 14 por 28 y 192 por 48 y 2 por
24 48 69 y 8 17 y llevamos 14 y 15
seguimos es claro 24 por 24 576 yo me
tengo que saber las tablas hasta el 25
por el 25 pero bueno esta vez no me
quería equivocar y ya tengo el 576 y
ahora sí 24 x menos 2 y 24 x menos 2 es
lo mismo entonces va a ser 24 por 2 por
2 es menos 96 x muy bien dese cuenta que
era un binomio cuadrado perfecto dos
veces el primero por el segundo 96 x ya
esto hay que sumarle el cuadrado del
segundo o sea 4 x cuadrado bien espero
que hasta aquí estemos en orden ahora lo
que tengo que hacer es multiplicar todo
por la x de fuera entonces me va a
quedar voy a ordenar lo de una vez para
que todo me quede más claro
4 x cúbica va a ser x x menos 96 x es
menos 96 x cuadrada y x x 576 6 576 x
voy a borrar la operación que tengo aquí
a la derecha y es que no debí de haber
hecho esta operación pero yo tengo
bastante orgullo en este momento y no me
quería equivocar
y tampoco decirles que no sabía entonces
mejor lo borramos bien entonces pues el
panorama que tenemos que seguir lo que
tengo que hacer es ya que tengo la
función de x puedes encontrar su primera
derivada igualar la 0 y sacar los puntos
críticos para ver si son máximos o
mínimos
ese es el menú para lo que sigue pero
para ello tener todo esto de hecho sería
muy bueno que ustedes hicieron el
experimento en casa y tener una hoja de
papel de 24 x 24 y cortarle cada una de
las esquinas y hacerlo un poco más
intuitivo un poco más práctico sin
embargo vamos a utilizar las matemáticas
y vamos a hacerlo una vez que no es la
primera derivada de v de x pues bueno b
prima de x es igual a 4 por 3 12 2x
cuadrada menos 96 por 2 es 6 6 12 192 x
y bueno que más 576
y bien yo lo que quiero es esta
expresión matemática igual a 0 obtener
una ecuación de segundo grado entonces
lo voy a poner aquí 12 x cuadrada menos
192 x + 576 esto tiene que ser igual a
cero bien entonces pues lo que se me
ocurre aquí primero es dividir todo
entre 12 creo que todo es divisible
entre 12 entonces vamos a dividirlo x
cuadrada y después es 192 entre 12 192
salió de multiplicar el 24 por el 2 por
el 2 por el 2 es decir 192 es lo único
que 24 por 8 y si los dividimos entre 12
es 16 x 16 les digo que no me quiero
equivocar y los vídeos pasados me
equivocado mucho realmente por eso no me
quiero equivocar entonces lo voy a hacer
aquí 192 entre 12 112 y sobran 7 bajamos
el 216 ahí está 16 es lo que les decía y
después 576
576 el dios de 24 por 24 pero si un 24
lo dividimos entre 2 m2 y entonces es 48
bien x cuadrado menos 16 x más 48 igual
a cero bien ahora lo que quiero son dos
números que multiplicados me den 48 y
sumados me den menos 16 voy a factorizar
esto sí está bien lo que dije haber 192
entre 12 6 16 y 576 entre 12 48 hoy
vemos desconfiado yo creo que esto me
pasa porque no es senado aún estoy como
que en el modo cálculo y no he pasado
álgebra 2 algo así me siento a ver vamos
a hacerlo de una vez aunque parezca
parezca vídeo de operaciones básicas
pues que lo quiero hacer porque porque
para sentir el dolor que ustedes sienten
cuando están en un examen
4 y entonces esto me sobran y 58 claros
y de 58 perdón perdón es que ando
desconfiado y no me quiero equivocar
esto es lo que pasa entonces bien dos
números que multiplicados me den
positivo 48 y sumados me den negativo 16
claro son 12 y 4 si de eso sí estoy
seguro entonces lo voy a anotar aquí de
una vez
si yo factor hizo esta expresión me
queda x
-4 ya esto lo voy a multiplicar por x 12
y esto es igual a 0 y dos cosas
multiplicadas son 0 si la primera es 0 o
la segunda es 0 si la primera es 0 pues
me queda que x es igual a 4 si la
segunda 0 me queda que x es igual a 12 y
ahora vamos a usar un poco la lógica
porque si x es igual a 12 entonces ya no
hay nada que hacer no es necesario
calcular la segunda derivada porque
porque si x vale 12 entonces 24 menos 2
por 12 es cero y si yo tengo una base de
cero pues es que tengo un volumen de
cero es decir este valor me hace que mi
función sea mínima mi volumen es cero
cuando x vale 12 entonces ya tengo la
respuesta x igual a 4 es aquel valor que
maximiza mi función y sacamos este punto
máximo con pura inspección y pura lógica
entonces x igual a 4 que ya sabemos que
es un máximo se vería graficado de esta
manera voy a poner como un pequeño
esbozo de cómo se vería graficado tiene
una concavidad hacia arriba
tanto me va a quedar así bien de todos
modos vamos a probar que si era un punto
máximo con la segunda derivada aunque ya
no sea necesario pero vamos a hacerlo
para no quedarnos con las dudas la
segunda derivada pues es 12 por 2 que es
24 x y menos 192 menos 192 y si
sustituimos el valor de 4 en x que me va
a quedar pues 24 por 4 es lo mismo que
48 por 296 no entonces 96 menos 192 y
esto es igual a 96 menos 96 gana el
negativo y es lo que queríamos queríamos
un valor negativo para la segunda
derivada y así x igual a 4 es un máximo
muy bien y si x vale 4 pues ya podemos
poner los lados una vez más nos quedamos
con la duda pues este lado vale 24 menos
2 por equis es 24 menos 8 que es 16 no
entonces este lado vale 16 éste equivale
también 16 y la altura vale 4 y 4 y una
vez más los desafío a que encuentren un
valor
x que haga este volumen más grande que
no sea 4 prueben intenten y van a ver
que no va a haber uno solo espero que
este vídeo te haya sido útil y nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo con otros
problemas de optimización